information uh in fact with some people
at the mathematical Research Institute
we currently prepare new application for
dhol seminar which is a onewe seminar
between computer science and sometimes
they allow economists there as well um
and the idea is that you have a one week
it's somewhat in the middle of nowhere
so we have lots of time to listen to
talks and actually also sit around in
working groups and the question is how
do you form working groups so
um so how do partition the participants
into the working groups also based on
the preferences of those participants
and that's basically a so-called honic
Coalition formation problem and I'm
going to talk about that and our focus
is on good outcomes well what are good
outcomes in our case we are thinking
about cor stability so an outcome is
this partition and we are thinking about
a new type of situation AKA preference
domains where we have existence of these
good good outcomes and on top of that
and that's the Sherry on the cake we are
going to have implementability in terms
of Truth telling in weekly dominant
strategies AKA strategy proofness so uh
the model is very simple so we have n
agents like you know you are sitting
here in this room and a non-empty subset
is called a
coalition and what we're going to have
is that people have preferences over the
coalitions that can be members
off um you don't care what the other
people do you just care about your own
group and the preferences of uh the
preference domain is denoted by R and
what we are interested in our preference
profile so I want your input of who you
want to be with uh in order to determine
what partitions we are going to uh look
at now hadon a game or for short a
problem is a set of agents and their
preferences over the coalitions that can
be members of so it's a very simple
model and an outcome for a problem is a
partition into coalitions and then you
consume your Coalition in a working
group for
instance now denote we denote partitions
by
pi and the preferences I'm going to talk
about are assuming that you are able to
consider how you think about another
person together with yourself one
assumption I make right now but I will
drop it at the end of the talk is that
you're not indiff between Al being alone
and being with somebody again I'm going
to drop it but for now we assuming this
now the moment I make this assumption I
can actually partition the set of Agents
into two types of groups namely the
friends so the friends are the ones
where I'm preferring being with this
person so maybe you know AA I would I
would prefer to be with him than sitting
alone and think about stuff so then Aela
is a friend and vice versa if I prefer
to be alone instead of being with
somebody then that person is an enemy of
course this is a bit strong right I'm
not really thinking about enemies and
and and friends but think about it you'd
rather want to work with somebody it's a
productive person in your working group
or you know for instance maybe
somebody's very quiet they just sit
there I still would rather not have them
there because maybe they end up on the
publication and then I'd rather not have
that coor who didn't do
anything so we we are going to divide
the set of people into you are going to
divide people into friends and enemies
and we are sometimes just denoting that
a little bit more simply without putting
the preferences as
inputs okay now we are not assuming that
this is symmetric you know I might think
you know ARA is my best friend but
actually he'd rather not see me so no
reason for this to be
symmetric now the point is that we will
use this to define a fairly big domain
of preferences called friend
oriented um so preferen are friend
oriented if adding only an enemies bad
you know there's somebody in my group
and who comes in I don't like them the
the group just became worse my Coalition
just became worse and of course I also
will assume that adding a friend is good
but here we are doing a bit more it's a
bit like putting more emphasis on the
friends you know you're talking about
research in the working group some
brilliant creative guy for me is much
more important than these people who sit
around and don't don't do much so
basically we are applying some
lexicographic tiebreaking here the favor
of friends I'm also going to mention
what happens if you do it the other way
around if you put the emphasis on on
avoiding enemies of course this could
happen as well it changes the result it
is important so this means that when I'm
adding a friend possibly with a set of
enemies it's still a better
set okay so we are going to denote the
domain of friend oriented preferences by
Script F and here's just a little bit of
a of an examp example that shows you
what happens so the notation means one
uh we look at a preference of agent one
he has two friends and a bunch of
enemies um the best set the best
Coalition for agent one is when he is
there and his best friends so the best
is always when you're together with just
your friends nobody else and then we can
see that when you add an enemy the set
gets worse and here we add even more
enemies the set goes down and here we're
removing a friend again that's super
important the friends important so again
the set getss worse so this is a better
set it has another friend there and now
we add an enemy again and so on now at
some point you're alone and down here
you have all sets that have only
enemies
okay now there are subdomains of these
friend oriented preferences that we can
easily illustrate one was introduced by
dimitro bom Hendrick and Sun uh they
called it appreciation of friends in the
Coalition formation context and
basically what you do is you just count
now you have two sets two coalitions you
could be a member of you count the
number of Friends the one that has more
friends is the better Coalition if you
have equal number of friends you just
count the enemies and the one with fewer
enemies is now the better Coalition so
you just count you have lots of
indifferences now we also introduced a
so-called lexicographic preference
domain where you have a ranking of
everybody so I rank you guys and I put
my somewhere so some of you are friends
some of you are enemies and in any
Coalition I just look at my best friend
the best person in that Coalition the
set with the best person is the better
Coalition for me now if the best friend
is the same I go to the second best and
so on so this is a lexicographic
extension of a linear order over
coalitions now this is of course only
having strict preferences this is a
strict preference
relation now here's a simple example
that illustrates to you quickly that
this is a big preference domain we have
four agents agent one has friends two
and
three uh and enemy four and you're
looking at the preferences of agent one
now there are 13 distinct preference uh
relations that are friend oriented seven
of them are strict the other ones have
some indifferences in them uh one is the
appreciation of friend preference
relation and of course since this guy
has two friends two be the best friend
or three can be the best friend friend
you have two lexicographic friend
oriented preference relations so I'm
just showing them to you here the weak
ones these have some indifferences
somewhere uh here you have the uh Le uh
here you have the two lexicographic
ones uh one and two and here you have
other strict friend oriented preferences
so that's just for this simple example
you already see you have lots of friend
oriented preferen
an now in this uh research on honic
Coalition formation there already has
been a preference domain that was
suggested as very nice because it
guarantees the existence of core uh
partitions of core Solutions uh and that
was the so-called top responsiveness um
domain by alcal
rier now top responsive I don't want to
spend a lot of time with this but they
work on Choice function so you give me a
bunch of Agents I'm able to say this
subset is my best set so part of this
preference domain is that each set of
Agents you can select the best set for
you from that it's a unique maximal
element of that choice function we just
saw Choice functions and then it happens
to be the case that uh first you have to
have that when the chosen set from s is
better than the chosen set from S Prime
then s is better than S Prime this is
not satisfied by all friend oriented
preferences by the way and the second
one is well if the choice from s is
equal than the choice from S Prime then
the smaller set is better this we have
because when you choose from a set the
best set from a set is only your friends
if two sets have the same
friends then the set with fewer enemies
wins and that's basically the second
condition first one is not
satisfied now what I want to illustrate
with this is that what we do is quite
independent of that domain here you have
the V diagram that illustrates the top
resp responsiveness domain the
appreciation of friends domain is in the
intersection with top responsiveness and
friend orientedness friend oriented
lexicographic preferences are completely
separated from top responsiveness and we
talk about domains that live in here
there can be everything there can be
parts of
this okay so here you have an example
with three agents uh agent one likes
agent two I'm just going to have
a quick diagram here that I will also
use and it agent one likes agent two
agent three likes agent
two and actually agent two likes both of
these
agents not going to denote that at the
moment and that implies unique
preferences for each of these agents
according to friend oriented preferences
I just have three agents and right now
it's just important that I have five
partitions everybody's alone everybody's
together or one person is Al
loone okay so we are interested in good
Solutions so I'm going to introduce core
allocations to you it's a very classic
concept you know you know in general
equilibrium we talk about course and
core allocations are are defined by a
blocking notion usually in economics
it's you take your endowment you
reallocate it and you get a better
allocation that's the blocking here what
you do is you split off in a in a
different Coalition because you're you
you your own endowment you can take
yourself somewhere else so a partition
is weakly blocked by a coalition if
everybody in the Coalition is at least
weekly better off and somebody strictly
better off weak blocking determines the
strict core because the strict core are
all the partitions that are not weekly
blocked by any Coalition and we Define
this we just you know the stct PO by
SC now there is weak blocking here if we
oh sorry there's another slide in
between uh clearly this there are two
specific blocking Notions you block with
yourself uh if that's not possible you
have an individually rational uh match
partition and you have Paro optimality
when the grand Coalition cannot weekly
block now the other blocking notion is
that of strict blocking or just blocking
that happens when the Coalition
everybody in the Coalition is strictly
better
off and the absence of blocking
coalitions defines the core and by
definition we can very easily see that
the strict core is always the subset of
the core that's just by definition it's
more difficult to block this way than in
the strict
core okay so one observation we can make
quickly is that the strict core can be a
strict subset of the core so here we
have this sort of example where agent uh
two uh agent so agent one likes agent
two agent three likes agent uh two and
the point is that agent two likes both
of these guys equally so he points here
and he points here but they are equal
friends that leads to preferences that
look like this because this is the same
to agent two and that's okay and now
what we can see is that there's a strict
core allocation namely the grand
Coalition because you know everybody
likes likes agent two so he has to be
member of any co uh you know Coalition
um and now we can see that there isn't
any weak blocking
um yeah to to that now what about the
red allocation over here for
instance so that
allocation could be uh blocked weekly
blocked by agent two who actually could
just go with agent three so here one and
two are together and that gives agent
one the best thing but agent two could
also now Block in a weak blocking with
agent three and move over here and agent
three is better off so basically between
the green and the red partition you can
Agent two can flip back and forth and
basically these are um core allocations
but not strict core
allocations so the strict core is just
the grand Coalition and the core
contains these other two allocations so
we can have a subset so
sorry this is too fast um so now the
point is how do you find core
allocations and now it turns out there's
this really neat uh thing going on that
you can construct a nice graph and the
graph theal con graph theoretical
concept gives you a core allocation so
what type of graph is it it's a very
simple graph everybody is a note in the
in the graph and what you do is you
point it's a directed graph you point at
your friends so here agent want has
friend has only friend two but agent two
is a bit more social he has friend one
five eight and three so everybody points
at their friends and you get the
so-called friendship
graph and now it turns out that strongly
connected components of the directed
graph are important so what does it mean
for a set of nodes or Vertes in the
graph to be connected it's a directed
graph so suppose I have a Vertex here
and a Vertex here I have to be able to
walk on the directed path from vertex a
to vertex B and from B to a so in other
words a set of nodes is connected if any
two nodes are on a conect on a directed
cycle now why do we say strongly
connected component well a strongly
connected component is a set of nodes
such that when you increase the set of
nodes it's not connected anymore it's a
maximal connected
set so here in the graph I of course
already marked them this is a strongly
connected component this is one so the
dotted Blue Area not the the nodes that
are um encircled by the blue Cycles are
actually strongly connected
components now those are sets of Agents
so hence a decomposition of a graph into
strongly connected components induces a
partition of
Agents now let me mention that strongly
connected components can be computed
very EAS easily there's a there
polinomial time algorithm for instance
one by tyion also the decomposition is
unique there's only one so I get a
unique partition out of this so we call
this the SEC the strongly connected
components
partition beautiful so we have the F
first main result of the paper that for
each problem with FR oriented
preferences the SEC partition is a
strict core partition
so it's not just the core partition it's
in the strict core meaning the strict
core is
nonempty okay now the strict core does
not need to be a Singleton we don't have
that here's an example it's again
similar to this but now agent two
prefers friend one so this here is a
better friend than the friend three so
now your preferences look like
this and now what you can see is is that
the grand Coalition again is a strict
core allocation but so is Coalition one
two and three is alone because again
here you don't have a weak blocking
because um so basically for this one uh
for agent two to get better off he needs
the grand Coalition and that's worth for
agent two so now basically you can
verify that uh there are two strict core
allocations it's not a unique concept
but if You observe something here you
see that the
second uh partition is a refinement of
the of the SEC uh uh partition so it's
taking the SEC partition and just
splitting it in smaller pieces and that
is actually a structural result it's a
necessary condition that if a partition
is a is core stable not just strict core
stable course stable then it has to be a
refinement of the SEC partition so we
know a little bit about the
that okay there's a coroller and this
plays a role for the next set of results
or mechanisms namely that if you have a
component that is a simp to
cycle minut I have 10 minutes okay
thanks if you have a component that's a
simple cycle that component occurs in
each uh core stable
partition um I'm I'm skipping this part
it's not so important but this is GRA
this this result is important for what
comes next next we look at mechanisms
that solve problems whenever they occur
a mechanism is a function that takes
subdomains from friend from the FR
oriented preference domain and assigns a
partition to each problem that occurs in
that sub
domain um just notation not so important
a mechanism satisfies stct qu stability
qu stability individual rationality pero
optimality if and only for science these
partitions with these
properties strategy proofness means that
it's a weekly dominant strategy to tell
the truth so if one agent changes his
report independently of what other
people do he cannot be better off we
also look at group strategy proofness if
a group of Agents you don't need to look
at the formulas group of us splits off
report something else it should not be
the case that we are all weekly better
off and some of us are strictly better
off I will later introduce we group
strategy proofness which uses the strict
manipulation we get together we report
something else and everybody is strictly
better off so that will be called weak
group strategy
proofness the mechanism that always
assigns the SEC partition is called the
SEC
mechanism and the mechanism that assigns
the SEC partition is strictly cor stable
we know that
but it's also group strategy
proof I'm not going to talk much about
the proof but the point is there's
something really nice happening you know
that if you have a decomposition into
SEC components you can Define the
so-called condensation graph where each
um component is shrunk you just contract
this into a single node and whenever it
has a outgoing arrrow that remains an
error in your graph so you can obtain a
condensation graph that graph is acyclic
and the acyclicity is important to prove
things because inductively you start
with the sync nodes of the condensation
graph you can show things for those guys
because those guys consider everybody
outside enemies and that helps to show
that actually they don't have an
incentive to manipulate their
preferences so you can show this group
strategy proofness stuff using the
condensation graph structure
now is this the only mechanism that
satisfies these nice properties
right and in fact we need some domain
richness condition here which is very
natural a domain from the friend
oriented preference is Rich if for each
possible
set of people you can be with there is a
preference report where you can declare
those your friends I'm able to make any
of you my friends so any set of you I
can make my friends in the preference
domain so then I have a rich
domain and then a mechanism on a rich
domain is course stable so now
notice we are talking here about strict
course
stability uh where is that oh that was
before um we were saying the
SEC uh mechanism is strictly cor stable
and group strategy proof but now I'm
weakening this to c St ility and
strategy proofness and I'm claiming a
mechanism is on a rich domain is core
stable and strategy proof if and only if
it's thec mechanism so to pin down the
mechanism the weaker properties are
enough but it satisfies the stronger
properties as
well okay now we constructed some
mechanisms that show
Independence I had individual
rationality and pero optimality up there
because one of the independ it's it's
not possible to weaken um stability into
pero efficiency and individual
rationality because then we have a
mechanism that satisfies that and uh
strategy
proofness now this is the main result
right so I have five minutes but I still
want to tell you that we did think about
what happens if you drop the
lexicographic aspect for instance if you
make the um if you make it more
important that you you minimize the
number of enemies now then results don't
hold because then already you lose the
existence of core partitions the core
may be empty so you have no hope to to
get even further results because now
core stability doesn't have a lot of
bite on the other hand what we could do
is we can add neutrals now adding
neutrals this is the front orientedness
conditions the only thing you add is
that you say listen when you add a
neutral your set remains indifferent to
you so they're truly
neutral now
then we have a notation and stuff uh
what is this example about this example
now shows that the strict core can be
empty because you have lots of
indifferences I'm not spending much time
here um but actually the SEC partition
is still a core allocation so the core
is non empty strict core can be
empty um does this thing satisfy group
strategy proofness
the answer is no because again this
example
serves uh basically agent two can make
agent one or agent three Happy by just
declaring them their friend and he
doesn't care so it's not group strategy
proof however group Strate weak group
strategy provement is going to be
satisfied um here we have an
impossibility theorem to have actually
uh crossability and group strategy
proofness I'm not spending much time
here I just wanted to say that we still
can preserve we group strategy proofness
because when we have uh friend oriented
preferences with neutrals I already
explained this to you it's a strict
benefic benefiting notion so then the
SEC mechanism is core stable in weekly
group strategy proof but there are
actually other mechanisms that satisfy
it now because now you can merge in
different sets in a certain way and it
gets quite
complicated with this I would would like
to thank you and all speakers of the
session
and minutes for
questions may I ask one yes
please the reach domain part usually one
needs to put jurisdictions to get some
existence result you
are like so for the for the Existence we
are fine right what's the intution for
keep the domain
reach
um so I mentioned to you that the when I
when we have a simple cycle then
basically that always has to be
component so the the proof of the
characterization result essentially
starts with a uh with one observation
that if you start deleting friends from
a profile such that the SEC components
don't
change then the solution outcome has to
still be the same Yeah so basically you
can can assume that your graph is
minimal with respect to the components
observation one then we start with a
proof that says well if one of your
components is a cycle we already have
the result that that component has to
occur now what we do is in a in a double
induction on number of Vertes and nodes
so this is super
fun um the next step is basically when
you now have a I just put the pen
back so this case is clear here so now
you essentially solve this case by
twisting it back to that and when you
understand this you understand that
that's the induction step where you
reduce on the number of
edges because this has one more Edge
than this one so when you manage to go
back you understand that there's a
little trick you can be doing in your
induction and in order to be able to go
from here to here you have to be able to
declare different
freps that's the intuition
any anybody else if not yes oh just um
so because of The Blocking this is all
like very computable like in like polom
or even even better than that right
you're not having any problems of like
uh situations where is this nonp poomi
or no absolutely not because the point
is the the strategy proofness forces uh
the mechanism to just look at who are
your friends basically what this says on
top I didn't mention it but it's a good
question it says listen forget about
your whole preference list just tell me
who your friends friends
are right I I don't care if if Atela is
my best friend and you are my second
best friend it's just they are my
friends we don't care about that
information so the strategy proofness
forces you to ignore a huge part of your
preferences and that will be fine and
then the computation of the SEC
components is polinomial these are old
algorithms in graph theory that work
wonderfully
well it's a bit it's a bit like you talk
about single Peak preferences for
certain things for voting or what not
and you say forget about the whole
preference relation just give me your
Peak that's what strategy proofness does
here thank you we can discuss all our
papers in the coffee break
now thank
[Applause]
you